wer weiß schon freuen
jeder tag ist
wer weiß schon heute wo wir morgen sind
immer und wieder alles neu beginnt
werden
tatsächlich ist doch einfach nur fußvolk
viele viele leute also scheint das ist
tatsächlich die beste currywurst gibt
wir waren lange auf der suche nach der
besten currywurst berlins also wenn
trubel zufolge muss ja irgendwas gehen
was gut ist oder sie sind umsonst
das werden wir herausfinden ich stelle
mich mit party auf keinen fall
ja klar stellt ihr euch an registrierte
makler curry 36 klingel klinge bei uns
sind die fahrradwege aber auch anders
gekennzeichnet hier ist es einfach nur
bei uns sind sie schwarz aber extra
hervorgehoben
aber ich bin ansteigen gewohnt weil bei
uns ist das oktoberfest
und da steht man lange vorm zelt riesen
lieb warum haben die hier also es gibt
hier eine currywurst ohne damen
ich werde mir eine klassische currywurst
mit pommes
ich hätte auch gerne currywurst mit der
bitte eines mario drauf
und rohe zwiebeln mitte und mit der eine
cola lustige vielen dank
also ist definitiv die wurst
dennis nimm doch in der trommel ist für
einen termin mit dem spruch eine partie
mit
es sind alles richtige berliner oder
alles saarländer
zumal lieber das sollte jetzt essen und
nicht filmen
der trip hat sich nicht unbedingt wegen
der currywurst wird hier ja sie war gut
keine frage aber es ist und bleibt eine
currywurst